what's going on guys my name is Dave
atomic welcome back to the channel today
we're talking about something a little
bit different but if you've been around
since the very beginning it's something
close to my heart we're gonna be talking
about some great at home fitness apps
which I think is essential to anybody
staying at home during the covert 19
crisis so we're going to be looking at a
number of different fitness apps that
I've personally used to try it out test
it and have a little bit of a play with
to see what they're like a couple are
really really good others not so much
we're predominately going to be focusing
on free at-home workout apps or apps
with free workouts in them that might be
paid as well so first of all it's one of
the biggest it's one of the best and
that is the naik fitness of training app
so the night app in my personal opinion
goes through a very clean setup process
it asks for some very basic details it
doesn't go too in depth and it doesn't
take too long some of the other apps
that I'm going to talk about later today
actually quite extensive and want to
know a lot of details and you can't just
get straight into what you're trying to
do so once you've finished your
introductory stage with the naik app
you'll find that most of the UI is very
clean very professional and very high in
photography obviously it's not it's one
of the most well known brands in the
world for health and fitness when you
dive into one of their fitness workout
programs one of the free ones especially
it downloads super super quickly
straight from their cloud unfortunately
it isn't a direct download play stream
like it is on YouTube but it is still a
very quick download once you're in the
workout you start following along it's
good to know that you can rotate the
screen and just have the whole screen as
the workout guide a voice guides you
through the entire workout so you don't
have to know what you're doing you just
listen to the voice by the instructions
on the screen
and go through the workout one exercise
at a time the one negative thing about
this app
however is the simple fact that the
voice-over for the exercises it's very
very monotone you have no idea if it's a
robot the pre-recorded voice or what it
is but it isn't the most exhilarating
and exciting voice to work out to so
that's definitely a con for the NICAP
overall the app is fantastic it does
deliver a lot of high quality workouts
and it is a very simple app to use I
like it generically for the fact that is
clean simple and doesn't take a long
time to get into moving on to an app
that's come out from a fitness
phenomenon and that's the Fitbit coach
as you know most people around you
probably have a Fitbit or some sort of
SmartWatch on them to track steps and
whatever fitbit's really do no idea
never owned a Fitbit but they're working
out app itself well personally I had
some issues with it so I don't really
know what it's going to be like
favorably else but in my experience it
wasn't the best so straight away from
the get-go when I started using the
Fitbit coach app and try to tap into a
few different workouts all I got
consistently was Network unavailable
Network unavailable Network unavailable
so I started thinking to myself okay
maybe it's my internet refresh to try it
again
nothing like but when you start moving
further down into the app you find a few
different free workouts that actually
did work so when I tried them out there
was a good few features you got to pick
between two different personal coaches
that you could either have the male
version of the female option train you
and it was a nice little option there
that gave you some sort of personal
choice well I didn't like though is when
I selected a trainer again they were a
little bit monotone and not really
genuinely enthusiastic about it they
weren't came to be in this app for the
program I feel in it as a result you
didn't really motivate me to workout I
felt like these apps were trying to be
like Nike but didn't execute it properly
the download speeds were incredibly slow
it took twice if not three times as long
to download a 15 minute work
on the app overall the UI is a little
bit clunky a little bit cluttered and
you don't really know what's going on
you can't find at your workouts as
easily as you could of an eye cap for
example so overall it is a decent app
but isn't perfect I think it wouldn't be
on my recommend list it would be online
take a look list for now until maybe
they updated it gets a little bit better
moving on to another leading name at the
added s training app is actually
phenomenal I think it is my number one
rated app on this list for the simple
fact that you sign up very quickly very
easily and then it goes straight into a
workout that's what you download these
fitness apps or to start working out you
don't have to troll through a whole
bunch of different information to try
find the right workout for you it
predicts based on the information you
put in a start what's going to be a good
first workout for you your straight into
it you've done your dusted it's over
again very high quality very
professional photography and videography
and a very clean UI this app is great I
don't know how to put it any other way
it's just as good as an eye cap if not
better because it does things quicker
and smoother and it's significantly
better than the Fitbit coach app it has
a variety of free workout programs for
all sorts of different levels but it
also does have a drawback because it
offers some paid features as well so not
everything on the app is going to be
100% free but if you find out that this
is a really good app and it's really
working for you maybe it is worth the
investment
I tested two other apps as well asana
and active a ativ so kind of like active
but not really both of these apps seem
to be really good from the get-go you
started using them they try to catch all
these information from you about your
workout experience and how qualified you
are and how good you are what you know
and it seems like they're going to
develop a really good plan for you but
once you get in them they start wanting
to charge straight away there's no free
content at least what I could find are
these apps which means it isn't
accessible enough but the
user and you just kind of have to pay on
a whim that the workouts going to be
good you don't get a test run of the
trainer or anything there so I think
these two apps could have some potential
but they're no nightmare no unless
they're not offering free incentives to
really get you on there and to provide
the greater good of having a healthier
fit lifestyle I guess is the main goal
of some of these apps which these two
apps are kind of just driving the
monetary business side of things and
lastly I want to talk about Jim sharks
app now Jim sharks app is only available
on an iPhone I don't know why it's not
available and Android just yet and you
can't run it on an iPad either you can
only run it on an iPhone however having
said this this is an app I have used for
many many weeks now
during the Coburn I think pandemic it is
an app that truly lets you pick your
trainers pick the personalities you like
and get the highest quality professional
photography videography inside one
platform most of it is free not
everything is free again similar to
added ass but at the end of the day they
offer some very high quality at home no
equipment required workouts and I think
the point of this video predominantly is
to find and access apps that offer no
equipment completely free workouts so
that you guys at home and myself
personally can actually get out and move
when you're stuck at home or stuck in
isolation I hope you enjoyed the video
if you did make sure you smash that
subscribe button
20:20 style and as always ask your next
Monday